AI has been a Hot Topic as of late
especially with the Advent of chat GPT
which is it turns out impacts the real
estate industry here to talk more about
that is Kirby Scofield of Scofield
Realty the sponsors of this segment
Kirby always good to see you oh thank
you GPT uh you know there's so many
different ways to use this and it turns
out this the the real estate industry is
no exception it has been such a cool
tool for us
um I mean pure and simple everyone wants
to look smarter right yeah and I'm not a
writer and most Realtors aren't writers
and when chat GPD we're able to utilize
it to do the right service to the client
make yourself look smarter and um it's
kind of amazing the stuff that comes out
of it when you program it and you how
you can use it yeah because you just say
include XYZ in an email format boom it's
done I mean you can do uh stuff that
we've been playing with that you can
tell to write in a certain Persona you
can tell it to write in a certain
reading level tell it to be more wordy
give me the Emojis give you the hashtags
so when it comes to our stuff
um listing presentations to uh marketing
material blogs content
um all your social posts you know I have
to be a writer anymore but you're able
to create it to the way you want and
then there's other tools involved with
it that you can make sure it's not
plagiarism yeah that doesn't look like a
bot that's SEO optimized like
originality.ai is one of the tools so
you're embracing all this yeah every
which way that we can do it and be
honest I'm like the worst email or
texter there is I cannot write for the
heck of it but now you can yeah now I
look I look smart so I'll take it do you
see AI though as a threat at all to your
industry not to our industry but I think
to the people that we used to hire for
certain things so I used to hire people
to write listening descriptions to write
out marketing material create the
brochures and stuff you give them the
points and then they'd make it look the
way you want and fill in the content
then this you can do on your own and
change it on a whim which is is
revolutionary it's amazing I was talking
to a composer who had done music for a
lot of movies and television shows and
he said you could use chat gbt to write
a score for a show and say you know you
want it to be dramatic music or western
music whatever it is yeah it's a score
songwriters people are scared of that
yeah because you have very own songs um
coding
it can you can tell it what you want to
code on a website it will write the code
yeah but when shopping for a home you do
want a human touch at the end yeah the
description and making it look as pretty
as the pictures that we do and as pretty
as your house shows yeah it's just
making the content look better and be uh
a better findable I don't even know the
word to use for that when you're on
Google yeah uh due to the content yeah
and to know you have a human Advocate at
the end of the day that's good another
thing is emails how many times
negotiating with someone else and you
don't want to come off too rough on the
situation you want to be professional
but at the same time get your point
across it will help you write the email
Kirby always great to see you really
appreciate it and as always we're
looking for people guys all right there
you go you heard it here thank you
Scofield Realty for sponsoring this
segment if you want more information or
learn who they're looking for visit
scofieldrealty.com or call the phone
number on your screen 702-941-7202